مساء الخير،
علينا ان نتوقف قليلا
لشرح أسباب تمرّد العرب على الأتراك
والذي ستستغلّه بريطانيا في حربها ضد الدولة العثمانية.
ثورة العرب على الباب العالي
كانت نتيجة حتمية للجرائم التي ارتكبها الجيش العثماني
في كل المناطق العربية على امتداد اربعة قرون
منذ هزيمة مماليك مصر في معركة مرج دابق في الشام سنة 1516
على يد السلطان سليم الأوّل
وصولا إلى فجر القرن العشرين
حيث ستبلغ سياسة التتريك القسري للعرب ذروتها
مع وصول جمعية الإتحاد والترقي وتركيا الفتاة إلى الحكم
بعد انقلاب سنة 1909 الذي أطاح بالسلطان عبد الحميد الثاني.
لم يشهد العرب عبر تاريخهم انحطاطا حضاريا
مثلما شهدوه وهم تحت نير الإحتلال العثماني.
النخبة العربية في الربع الاخير من القرن التاسع عشر،
نذكر منها احمد عرابي وجمال الدين الأفغاني ومحمد عبده ومصطفى كامل،
لم يكن مطلبها الإستقلال عن الباب العالي
بل فقط المطالبة بحكم ذاتي للأقاليم العربية داخل الخلافة العثمانية
والفصل بين ما هو ديني إسلامي و ما هو وطني قومي.
لكن في الربع الأوّل من القرن العشرين،
وبعد ان يئست هذه النخبة من إمكانية إصلاح الخلافة العثمانية،
بدأت في المطالبة بالإستقلال عن الباب العالي،
وتجلّى ذلك بوضوح
في كتاب طبائع الإستبداد لعبد الرحمان الكواكبي،
وكتاب "إحياء الأمة العربية" لنجيب عازوري
الذي صدر في باريس سنة 1905.
تنامى الشعور القومي عند عامة الناس في كافة الأقطار العربية.
وتشكّلت نخبة عربية قومية من بلاد الشام أساسا
لجأت إلى مصر هربا من جحيم جمال باشا
الحاكم العسكري التركي للشام وقتئذ،
والملقّب بالسفاح
والذي قام بإعدامات جماعية لعدة رموز قومية في دمشق
منهم أصدقاء ومقرّبون للأمير فيصل بن الشريف حسين.
وممّا زاد العرب يقينا
ان مصيرهم لم يعد مرتبطا بمصيرالأتراك،
هوّ عجز الخلافة العثمانية (الرجل المريض)،
عن حماية الأقطار العربية من الأطماع الإستعمارية،
الجزائر وتونس كانت مستعمرات فرنسية
والسودان ومصر وجزء من الخليج العربي مستعمرات بريطانية
وليبيا سلمتها الخلافة العثمانية للإستعمار الإيطالي
بمقتضى معاهدة أوشي التي أبرمتها مع إيطاليا سنة 1912.
في آب/أغسطس سنة 1914،
بعد قرار دخول الدولة العثمانية الحرب العالمية الأولى
إلى جانب دول المحور؛ ألمانيا والنمسا وبلغاريا
ضد دول الوفاق بريطانيا وفرنسا وروسيا،
سيصدر السلطان العثماني محمد رشاد فرمانا يعرف بالسفر برلك،
وهي كلمة تركية تعني النفير العام،
وجاء في هذا الفرمان؛
أن كل الرجال في أراضي الدولة العثمانية من المسلمين وغير المسلمين،
الذين تترواح أعمارهم بين 15 و 45 سنة
عليهم الإلتحاق بالخدمة العسكرية الإجبارية.
العرب في الشام والحجاز والعراق سيكونون أول ضحايا فرمان السفر برلك
وسيفقدون عشرات الآلاف من أبنائهم في حرب عبثية لا ناقة لهم فيها ولا جمل.
أهل الشام والحجاز والعراق سيطلقون على هذه السنوات
التي شهدت كذلك تفشي المجاعات والأوبئة
أيام الضيم والهلاك.
الشريف حسين في مكّة
سيرفص رفضا مطلقا طلب السلطان العثماني
دعوة المسلمين للجهاد المقدّس  ضد دول الوفاق،
وسيطالب البريطانيين والفرنسيين بمزيد تقديم الدعم العسكري لجيشه
الذي تمكّن بقيادة ابنه فيصل والعقيد توماس ادوارد لورانس
من تحقيق انتصارات عسكرية كبيرة على الأتراك في منطقة الحجاز.
لورنس سيعمل على اقناع القيادة البريطانية في القاهرة
والأمير فيصل بن الشريف حسين،
بتوسيع جبهة القتال ضدّ الأتراك،
يقول في كتابة أعمدة الحكمة السبعة ":
"ان الحرب العربية كانت جغرافية،
والجيش التركي كان وجوده هناك عرضيا،
وهدفنا كان يكمن في السعي لمعرفة النقاط الأضعف لدى العدو
ونركّز عليها لنُنهكه مع مرور الوقت.
اما مصدر قوتنا،
وأعني رجالنا وقواتنا من البدو
الذين يجب ان تُرسم وتُعتمد عليهم الحرب،
فكانوا غير معتادين على العمليات العسكرية النظامية،
الا أن لهم مرونة التحرك، والشدّة، والثقة بالنفس،
والمعرفة التامة بالبلاد، والشجاعة والذكاء.
وسيكون تشتيت القوات التركية بواسطتهم ناجعا.
بالتالي ينبغي علينا ان نوسع جبهتنا إلى اقصى ما يمكن،
وذلك لنفرض على الأتراك اقامة اطول خط دفاعي ممكن،
حيث انه سيكون من الناحية المادية،
من اكثر اشكال الحرب تكلفة".
العلاقة الوطيدة بين الأمير فيصل و العقيد لورنس
لا تعود إلى التقارب بين شخصيتيهما فحسب،
بل انه كان للرجلين طموحات متماثلة،
كلاهما كان يعتبر ان السيطرة على دمشق
هي مفتاح نجاح الثورة العربية
لبناء الكيان العربي الجديد
الذي سيجلس على عرشه الأمير فيصل.
الطريق إلى دمشق تمرّ حتما عبر الإستيلاء على ميناء العقبة
الذي يقع في الطرف الشمالي للبحر الأحمر.
لورنس سيفاجئ الأتراك ويهاجم ميناء العقبة برّا وليس وبحرا
وسيعتمد أساسا على دعم قبائل الحويطات
بقيادة شيخهم عودة أبو تايه،
الذي يصفه لورنس فيقول:
" انه مقاتل يحمل هالة القرون الوسطى الرومانسية،
ينظر إلى الحياة باعتبارها ملحمة،
كل الأحداث فيها مهمة،
وكل الشخصيات على امتدادها بطولية،
وذهنه حافل، تتدفق منه قصص الغارات القديمة
وقصائد المعارك الملحمية».
بعد السيطرة على ميناء العقبة
ستصبح للورانس حظوة كبيرة لدى القيادة العسكرية البريطانية في القاهرة ولندن
وسيغدو عنصر الربط المباشر بين الأمير فيصل والقوات العربية
والجنرال إدموند اللنبي،
الذي كان قد وصل إلى مصر
ليتولّى قيادة جبهة فلسطين لمهاجمة الجيش العثماني هناك
والسيطرة على القدس.
بعد العقبة،
سيبدأ لورنس في الإعداد والتخطيط للتوجّه إلى دمشق،
ومما يثير دهشة قارئ كتاب أعمدة الحكمة السبعة،
هو مدى معرفة هذا العقيد الإنجليزي بجغرافية الشام
ودقّة وصفه لتنوعها العرقي والديني،
يتحدّث في كتابه عن طبائع الأرمن والتركمان والأكراد في الشمال
وعن العلويين في الساحل
وعن السريان المسيحيين
ويتحدّث عن الدروز،
والشركس القادمين من بلاد القفقاز
ويتحدّث عن اليزيديين الذين تأثّروا بالمانوية الفارسية،
ويتحدّث عن الطائفة الإسماعيلية الأكثر ولاء للإنجليز،
ثم يتحدّث عن المسيحيين في لبنان
المنقسمين إلى موارنة موالين لفرنسا وروم ارثوذكس موالين لروسيا.
ويتحدّث عن اليهود في فلسطين
ووصفهم بأنهم خليط عجيب من الأجناس والأنواع
وأشار إلى بداية الإستيطان الصهيوني في فلسطين
من طرف مجموعات يهودية ألمانية متطرفة ناطقة بلغة اليديش.
ويصف مدن الشام،
فيقول:
ان دمشق هي رأس سورية
ومركز الحكومة المدنية،
وقطب ديني كبير،
شيوخها هم أصحاب الرأي فيها،
وسكانها مستعدون دائما إلى اللجوء إلى العنف،
متطرفون في أفكارهم بقدر ماهم جانحون في ملذّاتهم.
و يتحدّث عن مدينة حلب فيقول:
هي ليست مدينة سورية ولا أناضولية ولا عراقية،
وذلك
لأن جميع الأعراق و الأديان واللغات المنتشرة
في كافة انحاء الإمبراطورية العثمانية توجد فيها،
حتى اصبحت أشبه ببرج بابل.
ويقول انه من خصائص حلب الفريدة ،
انك تجد فيها رغم حرارة الإيمان
تآلفا غريبا وتعايشا سلميا
بين المسيحيين والمسلمين واليهود،
وبين الأرمن والعرب والأكراد والأتراك.
لورانس،
هذا القائد العسكري
رغم حدّة ذكائه
إلا انه أحيانا كان على درجة كبيرة من التهوّر.
اثناء قيامه برحلة استطلاعية داخل مدينة درعا السورية
التي كانت تحت سيطرة الجيش العثماني،
ألقى عليه الجنود الأتراك القبض،
ومن حسن حظّه،
انهم لم يتعرّفوا عن هويته الحقيقية،
وقدّم نفسه على أنّه شركسي من القُنيطرة،
واسمه أحمد بن بكر.
الأتراك كانوا قد رصدوا جائزة مالية كبيرة
لمن يأتي لهم بلورانس حيا أو ميتا.
لورانس سيودع بمركز الإيقاف العسكري
على أساس انه جندي عثماني شركسي فار من جبهة القتال،
وفي المساء،
سيقدّم كغنيمة جنسية للضابط التركي المشرف على المعسكر،
لورانس يصف حادثة اغتصابه في كتابه اعمدة الحكمة السبعة
بحسرة شديدة،
وهذا الاعتداء سوف يخلّف له جرحا معنويا عميقا
وسيكون بمثابة الثقب الأسود في ذاكرته.
في ليلته الثانية،
سيترك له احد الحرّاس،
تبين للورانس من لهجته انه درزي سوري،
باب الزنزانة مفتوحا
ليتمكن من الفرار من المعسكر مع طلوع الفجر.
سنة 1917،
تمكّن الشيوعيون من الوصول إلى الحكم في روسيا
بقيادة فلاديمير لينين،
وسيكشفون عن معاهدة سايكس/ بيكو،
وهي معاهدة وُقّعَت بين كلٍّ من فرنسا وبريطانيا
تحت إشراف روسيا القيصرية سنة 1916،
وأمضاها كل من "مارك سايكس"
المندوب السامي البريطاني لشؤون الشرق الأدنى
ونظيره الفرنسي "جورج بيكو"،
وقَضَت هذه المعاهدة بتقسيم الدول العربيّة
التي تقع في الجزء الشرقيّ من البحر الأبيض المتوسط،
والتي كانت تخضع لسيطرة الدولة العثمانيّة
بين كلٍّ من بريطانيا وفرنسا.
توماس إدوارد لورانس
سيجد نفسه في مأزق امام رفاق سلاحه من العرب،
ورغم شعوره بمرارة خيانة بلده وتنكرها لوعودها تجاههم
سيواصل تضليلهم بتأكيده لهم ان بريطانيا لن تتراجع
على ما وعدت به الشريف حسين،
في المقابل
نصح الأمير فيصل بضرورة الإعداد للهجوم على دمشق
والسيطرة عليها
كي يتمكّن من الدفاع عن حقوق العرب امام دول الوفاق
من موقع أكثر قوّة.
يقول لورنس في كتابه أعمدة الحكمة السبعة  :
" لم اكن قد اطلعت مطلقا،
بصورة رسمية او شخصية على الوعود التي قطعها مكماهون،
ولا على معاهدة سايكس/ بيكو،
فجميعها كانت قد تمّت عن طريق مكاتب الخارجية البريطانية،
وبما انني لم اكن أحمق،
فقد رأيت ان وعودنا التي قطعناها للعرب،
في حالة كَسْبنا للحرب، ستبقى حبرا على ورق.
وهكذا، كان عليّ، لو كنت مستشارا شريفا،
ان انصح رجالي بالعودة إلى ذويهم وديارهم
عوضا عن المخاطرة بحياتهم في سبيل قصص وخداع من هذا النوع.
ولكن،
ألم تكن الحماسة العربية أفضل أداة نستخدمها في حربنا في الشرق الأدنى؟
وهذا الأمر هو الذي حملني على ان أؤكد لرفاق السلاح من العرب
ان انجلترا ستحترم وعودها نصا وروحا.
فما ان نال الثوار العرب هذا الوعد مني
حتى دبّت الحماسة من جديد
وراحوا يحاربون بشجاعة فائقة.
اما أنا،
عوضا ان افتخر بما كنا نحرزه معا من انتصارات،
فقد كان يلازمني شعور مرير بالخجل
لعلمي بأن ما قلته لا قيمة عَمليّة له."
ثمّ يُضيف:
" مما حملني
على ان أقسم بيني وبين نفسي
على أن أجعل من الثورة العربية اداة تعمل لغاية ذاتية،
أكثر منها خادمة لجيشنا البريطاني،
وأخذت على نفسي عهدا ان أقودها، بأي ثمن،
إلى النصر على الرغم من انتهازية الدول الكبرى."
في صباح غرّة تشرين الأوّل، أكتوبر 1918،
دخل لورنس دمشق على رأس جيش الأمير فيصل
بعد انهيار الجيش العثماني،
وقام بطرد الأميرين عبد القادر الجزائري وشقيقه محمد سعيد من دمشق.
وعيّن شكري باشا الأيوبي حاكما عسكريا
ونوري السعيد قائدا عاما للقوات المسلحة.
ثمّ توجّه مباشرة، في حركة رمزيّة،
إلى ضريح صلاح الدين الأيوبي
ليستولي على الإكليل الذهبي الّذي وضعه فوقه الإمبراطور الألماني
خلال زيارته لدمشق سنة 1898،
معتبرا إياه غنيمة حرب
وأهداه لاحقا للمتحف الإمبراطوري الحربي في لندن.
بعد يومين،
في الثالث من تشرين الأول/ أكتوبر
سيصل إلى دمشق الأمير فيصل ليلتقي بالجنرال ادموند اللنبي،
وينهي رسميا 400 عاما من السيطرة العثمانية على دمشق.
في نفس هذا اليوم،
سيطلب العقيد توماس ادوارد لورانس من الجنرال إدموند اللنبي
انهاء مهامه والسماح له بالعودة إلى لندن.
يقول لورانس في آخر فقرة من كتابه أعمدة الحكمة السبعة:
" كانت مهمتي في الإجتماع بين الأمير فيصل والجنرال اللنبي
ان أقدم كلاهما للآخر واتولّى عملية الترجمة بينهما.
وبعد ذهاب فيصل
التمست من اللنبي السماح لي بالعودة إلى بلادي.
فأجابني مصرّا بالرفض.
ولكنني نجحت في اقناعه بأن الأمور تسير أحسن بدوني،
وسيشعر العرب حقيقة بأنهم أصبحوا أحرارا ومستقلّين.
فوافق على ذهابي.
وعندئذ شعرت بالحزن يمتلكني.
عاد لورنس إلى لندن
ليشهد صناعة أسطورة لورنس العرب
التي سيقوم بها أساسا الصحفي الأمريكي لويل توماس
الذي سمحت له بريطانيا بالتغطية الإعلامية للثورة العربية الكبرى،
ونقل الإنجازات العسكرية لضابط الإتصال الإنجليزي توماس إدوارد لورنس
لإقناع الرأي العام الأمريكي
بمساندة معسكر الوفاق ضد ألمانيا والنمسا وتركيا.
سيقوم لويل توماس بتقديم عدة محاضرات في لندن
حول الثورة العربية الكبرى وهزيمة الأتراك والألمان
مستغلا كل ما جمعه من صور خلال تغطيته للأنشطة العسكرية للورنس
في منطقتي الحجاز والشام،
و ستشهد هذه المحاضرات إقبالا منقطع النظير من البريطانيين
المحتفين ببطلهم توماس ادوارد لورنس
الذي تحوّل إلى أسطورة.
بعد نهاية الحرب العالميّة الأولى بإنتصار دول الوفاق،
ذهب الأمير فيصل إلى باريس لحضور مؤتمر الصلح سنة 1919
ممثّلا عن والده الشريف حسين،
وكان "لورانس" ضمن الوفد المرافق له،
ويقيم في جناح الأمير،
ويُذكر أنّه كان يرتدي اللباس العربي عندما يكون مع "فيصل"
ويستبدله بالزي الرسمي البريطاني عندما يكون مع وفد بلاده.
عاد الأمير فيصل من باريس بخفّي حنين
فلا طال توت الشام،
ولا عنب اليمن،
وتبخّرت وعود "مكماهون" للعرب
وحلّ محلّها وعد "بلفور" لليهود.
في التاسع عشر من شهر أيار/ ماي سنة 1935،
تُوفي العقيد توماس ادوارد لورانس عن ستة وأربعين عاما
بعد سقوطه من دراجته النارية في محيط مدينة اكسفورد.
رحل الرجل الذي لم يكن مهندس خريطة الشرق الأوسط
بعد سقوط الإمبراطوريّة العثمانيّة فحسب
بل كذلك مهندس صورة "العرب" في مخيّلة "الغرب" لعقود من الزمن،
من خلال فلم المخرج البريطاني الكبير "دافيد لين"
الذي اخرجه سنة 1962 وحمل عنوان (لورنس العرب)،
والمقتبس من كتابه أعمدة الحكمة السبعة.
توماس إدوارد لورانس،
بطل في عيون البريطانيين،
وصديقا وفيا في عيون العرب،
و جاسوس في عيون الأتراك.
الورقة
التي لم تسقط في فصل الخريف،
هي خائنة في عيون أخواتها،
ووفية في عين الشجرة،
ومتمرّدة في عيون الفصول...
فالكل يرى الموقف من زاويته.
هكذا قال،
الكاتب الروسي الكبير مكسيم غوركي.
اشكركم جزيل الشكرعلى المتابعة،
دمتم بخير،
وإلى لقاء قريب على قناة
أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود…